good day and welcome i'm jack van horn from the
university of virginia please allow me to welcome
you to this edition of our 20 20 21 foundations
of biomedical data science seminar series
this lecture is supported by uva's integrated
translational health institute of virginia
the uva brain institute the
college of arts and sciences
the school of data science and by a grant from the
national institutes of general medical sciences
it's my honor and privilege today to welcome our
speaker dr robert williams who is the u university
of tennessee oak ridge national laboratory
governor's chair in computational genomics
again from the university of tennessee he
completed his bachelor's degree in psychobiology
from the university of california santa cruz
in 1975 and earned his phd in physiology from
the university of california davis in 1983. from
1983 to 1985 he was a postdoctoral fellow at yale
university school of medicine in the section of
neuroanatomy where he was supervised by the famous
and noteworthy pasco rakesh his professional
experience involves a number of different
positions um mainly at the university of uh
tennessee over the almost the last 25 to 30 years
um he's also held positions at the university
of california davis um at yale university and um
has had many um organizational and societal
leadership roles amongst his many activities
and many pursuits professor williams has an
intense interest in systems genetics complex
complex trait analysis and functional genomics
as well as the control of gene expression the
genetics of cns disease and addiction the
role of the environment in disease modeling
of neurological syndromes visual system
architecture function and development
he's also been very concerned with advanced
methods in collaborative research and data sharing
over the last several years he has led the
informatics center for mouse neurogenetics
at the university of tennessee and this effort
hosts the mouse brain laboratory and expanding
collection of high-resolution histological
images atlases and databases on brain structure
in more than 120 different lines of experimental
mice working in his laboratory includes several
useful or sorry work in his laboratory include
several useful genetic and gene mapping databases
and as we were talking before we began today he
reminded me that the gene network.org database
has been in constant operation since 1995. he's
been a key participant in a number of several
large nih-funded programs including the nih human
brain project and more recently the nih brain
initiative he has won numerous awards including
the lauren d carlson award prize in physiology
the fellow award for the winter conference in
brain research as well as many others his lecture
today is entitled data structure disease risk gxc
and causal modeling and as always if you are um
watching this video via youtube we welcome you and
also our specially selected 2020 2021 biomedical
data science innovation lab participants are
encouraged to submit any questions for dr williams
via the chat feature in your zoom session i'll
synthesize these questions and i will ask them
on your behalf in the last 10 minutes or so of
dr williams lecture and with that welcome rob we
really appreciate your lecture and uh look forward
to hearing from you delighted to be here today
thank you very much for the invitation and
for that uh very very kind introduction um
this will be i've been accused of giving lectures
a little bit like toad's wild ride at disneyland
and so strap strap in well i'll try to get through
quite a bit uh but leave enough time for you to
ask questions and for me to attempt to answer your
questions the premise is right up here and i think
jack already highlighted some of these ideas uh
virtually all of the diseases we care about uh
the ones that are pervasive that are age-related
are a mix of genetic factors and variants and
lots of lots of environmental factors and of
course the non-linear interaction between those
two extremely tough problem to solve particularly
when you're dealing with human genomes where
each one of us unless we're fortunate enough to
have an identical twin is an n of one genome uh so
the the kind of um challenge uh slash hubris
of accurate medicine or precision health care
uh it's it's really going to be difficult
frankly because with an n of one it's difficult
to establish models it's difficult to know uh
what's good for you in specific it may not be
daunting to figure out what's good in general
for a population but figuring out what it what
it would be truly individualized health care that
is going to be very difficult so the task that
i've set myself over the last 20 years even before
we you know had this phrase precision healthcare
is how to build up systems data systems that
will allow us to approach the problems and so
the first top part of my talk i'm really
going to be talking about data types in a
way that i think is a bit unusual and i'll
explain that but the bottom line is we need
new types of data uh steven friend used to call
this or maybe still does call this coherent
data what is coherent data and i'm going to
re-badge that as multiplicative uh data types
and i'll show you how we're able to generate
multiplicative data types and the important
thing about having multiplicative data
types is that the lifespan of the data
is exceedingly long the quality of the data
oddly enough actually improves with age and
so you can be sure that if you make generate the
right kind of data using the right data generation
process your data will outlive you and presumably
become more and more valuable as the context
in which that data lives those data become
richer essentially i'm going to focus mainly on
neurogenetics because that
is my my area of strength
but a little bit on aging which is why this grim
reaper cartoon is also relevant so let's go to
so the first question a lot of you are
are formal data scientists and i'm going
to introduce what i think is a new term
smart data well maybe it's not so so so new
uh there's the the classic fred
brooks uh quote in the upper right
write stupid code that uses smart objects um smart
data and then the rule at the bottom uh rule five
of rob pike data dominates if you've chosen
the right data structure and organize things
well the algorithm will almost always be
self-evident data structures not algorithms
are central to programming i think that's
an arguable statement especially in this ai
driven world now but it it reveals something
that's very important there's a lot of data
generation a lot of consideration about curation
cleanup wrangling of data but less so about the
nature the fundamental nature of data so what what
do i mean by smart data and you know i could read
through this but do we need good metadata data
without great metadata is really not data at all
of course the data has to be qc'd for outliers
has to be transformed just to be wrangled
it has to be stabilized and put into a data
structure preferably one that's free in open
source software so that you can get at it unless
there are confidentiality issues uh hipaa issues
so we want our data to be fair but i would argue
that fair isn't nearly enough and fair data while
it may not evaporate it is really generally only
additively useful and i've shown the ice cube
metaphor there in the in the middle left of the
slide most data sets we generate alas particularly
those that are generated by nih ro1s are are
vulnerable to evaporation and um there have
been a several challenges both for data and for
code can you go back 10 years in your lab in your
research career and fish out your 10 year old data
and rerun the same algorithm you ran 10 years ago
that is an extremely challenging task and we tried
it here um about three months ago just to see how
far we could get we did get 10 years back one of
one of us one of my colleagues got 20 years back
but it's it's tough so most data exists
for the purpose of writing your cool paper
after your cool paper has been written most
of your data is now uh essentially orphaned
and if it lives on past five or ten years then
you're doing something right but it's still
additive data in other words your data
might add to the corpus of data but it's
not multiplicative so i'm going to explain
what i mean by multiplicative data pretty soon
just some examples of what i regard as
multiplicative data multiplicative data
is data where if you add one vector of data
or one matrix of data it integrates with many
other vectors and matrix or tensors of data and
now instead of just adding one correlation or
one edge to a network you're adding one
times whatever is already in that system
so in my case for gene network for the bxd family
we have billions of millions of phenotypes sorry
and for every additional vector we now have
millions of correlations that we that are actually
not just correlations or in a causal network as i
will explain but framingham heart study is a good
example of multiplicative data the genome genotype
to tissue expression database protein database
allen brain atlas and gene network these are a few
they're actually quite a few of these of course
they tend not to be r01 work though they
tend to be large program projects that
have been shepherded quite carefully by nih staff
including people like phil bourne and and jack um
even if the data are multiplicative very few of
these data sets come with integrated code and
services that can be used long term so geo is
a good example of the gene expression omnibus
of a massive data but there's not much you
can do with it if you're a mere mortal if
you happen to be a really good data wrangler
then you can do something with it but but
it's a major effort because geo actually doesn't
provide sophisticated analysis services and then
here's the final challenge what really makes data
smart is if the data gets better with age and
i can't you know it's so few day to get better
with age it's ridiculous but data should
in principle get better with age so um so
what does smart multiplicative data look like
so i'm going to give you a real world example of
this but the the short version is i'm interested
in brain weight you know in the next slide i'll
show you you know what what's the motivating
question for me but i'm particularly interested
in brain architecture and its variability
mouse brains weigh for different strains weigh
anywhere from about 380 to 520 milligrams so
half a gram roughly but there's a wide range so
you can see there one of the strains of mice the
one that's sort of a beige brown color has a brain
that's 402 milligrams on average and the other uh
strain of mouse black six has a brain that's about
471 milligrams on average and the error terms are
very small in this case because we've studied
literally hundreds of these animals under all
different kinds of conditions and by the way to to
finesse any question there is zero sex difference
in brain weight in uh mice and i've looked
at several hundred strains so uh brain weight
differences uh despite the smaller body weight
of females uh it just doesn't happen in mouse
so if i generate a vector of data in this case we
have data for about 95 different strains of mice
what can i do with that data so that's a vector of
numbers 95 deep and now i can compute correlations
of that vector with anything else i happen to have
measured in the same family of mice and we happen
to have measured millions of traits in the same
family of mice and you can see in the lower right
a correlation matrix of behavioral traits
expression traits with brainwave traits
so in that sense the if i add one vector i add
millions of correlations and as i'll show you that
is not merely correlation and if you wanted to get
to the this particular data set that i'm showing
you right there there's the web url any of you
can click on that web url or type it in god forbid
and it'll take you to essentially this
histogram and you can play with it
and you can calculate the correlations so
that's what i mean by multiplicative data
for the bxd family these are jack mentioned
that i i have an interest in gene expression
both protein expression in brain for which we
have precious little data for any species uh
and gene expression where the platform has
enabled us to get generate a lot of data
over the last 20 years but here's these are
massive expression data sets for hippocampus
from these same animals for which we have brain
weight so we have hippocampal precursor cell
expression data we have exon array data we have
proteomics data and i'll i'll give you a live tour
of some of that at some point so why i needed
uh smart data so when i started so i as jack
mentioned i was a postdoc with poshko rakesh
and developed some methods for counting cells
in poshko's highly highly diverse collection of
mouse brains some were processed in paraffin some
in soloidan some frozen sections they
were a histological mess of confounds
and i developed a method that now most of you
probably know is a dissector method we called
it three three-dimensional counting which allowed
us to get accurate stereological data out of this
hodgepodge of um and the reason i was interested
in this because i really wanted to know how
how are how are neurons in particular but glial
cells also and even endothelial cells how are the
numbers of those cells deployed across different
cns systems to generate function and behavior
it's a question you might be able to answer for
one structure in five or ten years but if you're
interested in answering that question across the
whole central nervous system even of a small brain
species like a mouse you're looking at hundreds
if not thousands of discrete cell populations as
we now know and the stereology simply didn't scale
so it was a question that couldn't be answered in
a stupid one at a time non-scalable method so my
my progression um sort of following the technology
so excel was introduced in 1987 and of course
i leapt on it because it was a huge boon
uh from doing things in a lab notebook god
forbid so at least it was one step up from a
hard copy lab notebook it's still unfortunately
maybe fortunately the lingua franca lowest common
denominator of data sharing with all of its warts
and ugliness and stupidity but it has worked to
a great extent and unfortunately i still use it i
can't i can't get away from it um the second step
is to move obviously to relational databases uh
the simple guys the them the microsoft accesses
and filemakers then to the the mysql maria db
postgres going to open source uh relational
databases is a big leap for most r01 funded labs
it's actually a huge leap because you need a lot
of expertise and it's not expertise you hire
for a couple of months you when you move into
this domain you are hiring somebody for the
rest of your career unless you are that person
so we've had one or two dbas working on
the systems i'll tell you since about 1990
myself initially when i had some level
of technical competence but now real pros
and then if you want to do what i wanted to do
which was live analysis of all of the data that
i would gather over my career you you can't say
okay i'm going to do it in r script and hope to
come back to that r script in 10 years the r
script is going to be too slow it's going to
be clunky um the whole you know somebody's going
to say no don't don't use r use rust because it's
way cool and it's got better garbage collection
or no garbage collection or use whatever d so
it's it's a constantly moving uh battle so we we
opted for web service um you know i think it was
a fortuitous decision we didn't know where the web
was going to go in 1995 but gene network started
as something called the portable dictionary of the
mouse genome um and it's still still going strong
okay uh so those were kind of my my steps
forward um oh and i think i've uh yeah so
three key resources to approach this question so
how are neurons generated how do they survive how
are they maintained uh throughout life span what
are the genetic factors and environmental factors
that do that so on the right of this slide
you see your typical motherhood and apple pie
data science slide going all the tiers of analysis
from dna variants at the bottom snips indels
bear and cnvs at the top environment disease
factors so sort of progressing up the tears
if you ask 90 of biologists what those
little brown and orange arrows represent
they will have no idea they will say
oh it's some kind of magic integration
arrow and they say well how do you actually
integrate across all these levels i said well
i don't know but you just get a mess of data for
your mouse say c57 black 6 or dba and now you're
going to be able to integrate that data if you're
lucky and that's essentially the approach that the
allen brain atlas did where they spent close to
300 million dollars studying c57 black six male
gene expression at 56 days of age that's an n of
one study that cost about a third of a billion
dollars i want you guys to think about that
because um i've been arguing with them for a
long time they did a wonderful thing for the allen
brain atlas so it's a it is a good expenditure of
money but it's not a great expenditure of money
why is it not great because it's an n of one
experiment that somebody just blew 300 million
dollars on fortunately it wasn't nih it was paul
allen but they could have done so much more if
they had incorporated genetic diversity and so
kind of in a parallel skunk works project that's
what i've been doing i'm trying to essentially do
allen brain atlas times about 10 000 using now
state-of-the-art methods and that's what i call
systems genetics so instead of an n of one i'm
going to look at my knockout or my knock-in
we're going to use integrative genetically aware
in other words variational wear not gene aware
but variation aware approaches that allow us
to compute models uh roc curves and get to
true prediction and in order to do that we need a
genetics reference family a stable immortal family
of experimental subjects i call them genome types
they're not genotypes but it's a whole genome type
that we can use for ever and ever all men as walt
disney would say throughout the known universe
and these mice are a stable resource they've
been cryopreserved your grandchildren will be
able to come back to them in 100 years rederive
essentially the same mouse that you studied
we've generated 150 of these over the last
30 40 years they've been very well sequenced
and all of the data is almost all of the data
is in gene network and so the idea is to get
high sample size to go to gene locus to gene
variant to mechanisms and to treatment options and
to answer the question i ask initially what are
these arrows represent initially they represent
correlations but they represent correlations in a
causal modeling environment which we get courtesy
of the central dogma which is to say that gna dna
variants cause phenotype variants not the other
way around so we have the causal polarity that
we need so this is the result of the second and
third decades of work in gene network i'm going
to just take you through a little bit of this
this is the example i already used once the
brain weight in males and females the 94
different different strains males and females
averaged and i said there's no difference
between the sexes so in this case we don't even
have to fit that as a cofactor although we could
and anybody who wants to explore these data either
as a data scientist interested in some fancy new
algorithm this is the most coherent phenome
data bar none for any collection of organisms
at this point there's nothing that approaches it
in terms of replication in terms of depth uh etc
and i will try to prove that i'm i'm bragging
obviously but let me i will try to prove that
uh and i just want to point out that all of this
smart data and all these correlations the family
has been fully sequenced fully genotyped it's like
a linkage study it's like tracking down the gene
variant that caused huntington in the venezuelan
population uh back in the in the 80s and 90s so we
can map the causes of variation to the genome that
sometimes goes by the name of a linkage analysis
or association analysis these are very unfortunate
terms because this is not mere linkage it's not
mere association it's a causal assertion it's a
causal model so in this plot that you're looking
at here that's called the manhattan plot on the
y-axis you have the minus log p of the association
so uh you know a value of six is pretty pretty
good that's point zero zero zero zero zero
one is a likelihood of uh of a false discovery
there at a conventional uh criterion on the
x axis are all of the chromosomes of
a mouse except except chromosome y in
the mitochondrial genome and you can see
we have two spots one on chromosome five
and one on chromosome 12 that have lod
scores above about 3.8 and those are
considered genome-wide significant so there's
a false discovery rate of about oh one in
call it one in a thousand or better for
that locus on chromosome five in other words
we know that there is a cause causal locus on
chromosome 5 that modulates brain weight with that
that caveat that the p value is good but obviously
it's not perfect um so this is a causal model and
all of this work actually we started in as part
of the human brain project that jack mentioned
so that is how we can add causality
to any correlation in gene network and
we have a a software stack the entire stack is on
github it's all open source you could just do a
complete fork and have a copy at uva and i'll tell
you i would be totally delighted if you did that
because we need more smart analysts and coders
we can't do this ourselves so coming back to that
original question what genes control variation
or what gene variants control variation in brain
structure here's here's our first conclusion
from a nature communications paper in 2012.
on the lower right you can see us
literally hand dissecting chunks
of the brain hippocampus striatum olfactory bulb
cerebellum all of those just were hand dissected
quite tedious but quite high throughput and from
that those data those became vectors of data so
there was a vector of data for how much is the
olfactory weight weigh how much is a cerebellum
way how much what is the volume of the cortex
or the striatum of the basal lateral amygdala
or the lateral geniculate nucleus and what you
see around that sagittal section are so-called
qtl maps of the type i just showed you in
this slide but now with continuous functions
rather than points for each snip so these are
just the continuous version so this is cortex
hippocampus whole brain which i just showed you
in the previous slide body weight as a cofactor
cerebellum algae and striatum bla and olfactory
bulb these data were published eight years ago
they are now much better than they used to be
because our genotypes for all these animals
are much much improved and we've sequenced all of
these strains using linked read technology so the
old data got better with age and i could you
know if if this were a jupiter lab notebook
i could give you this paper and say push this
button updated to the latest and greatest
version of these data and you could then tweak
the model you could say oh i don't like the way he
modeled x y uh we have to have sex as a co-factor
or do the interaction term and all that would be
possible if this data were embedded in the right
web resource it turns out it more or less is
so today so this is where jack and i were having
fun before the the before we got started here
so it still doesn't scale cutting up brains
literally with a with a scalpel is not the
smartest way to do this the smartest way to
do this is with magnetic resonance imaging
but magnetic resonance imaging has not been high
throughput at the resolution required for the work
that i'm interested in doing but fortunately as
part of the human brain project and the and the
burn network after that i struck up a a really
great collaboration with g allen johnson and duke
the director of the center for in-vivo microscopy
there who is a physicist and mri guru who has been
lucky for me adopted by the neuroscience community
and so he he is now this is a paper that just
came out a few about a month ago um each one of
these images that you're seeing here this is a
horizontal section through the mouse brain in
skull so the skull has been stripped but this is
in situ so to speak olfactory bulb at the top
cerebellum at the bottom this is this this is an
overlay of four brains from a black six male c
57 black six the mother of our bxd family this is
same thing for for four females and i just
want you to look at the male female difference
again the registration of these brains
within an isagenix strain are just phenomenal
and there are subtle quantitative differences
that won't leap out at you except over here where
we don't have a corpus callosum in the btbr
strain you can see the connection across the
midline is missing but what's amazing to me is the
similarity between male and female within strain
even to little dorky things having to
do with the shape of the olfactory bulbs
it's it's it's just it's just striking how
tight the genetic control is and how little
uh little there is in the way of sex difference
in this particular case obviously for those of
you who are sex difference aficionados i
don't understand it humans are obsessed by
sex and i'm just trying to wrap my head around
that and i still i still really can't um but
you can i you know there are going to be some sex
differences down here in the pre-optic area but
um really the amazing thing is how similar
uh male and female mouse brains are and
i think the same at a appropriate
generalization is also true of humans
the within the between strain difference the
genetic variation however is very sizable
so that's the the the mri and the the
connectomes which you see there so we're actually
following the diffusion metrics of water
protons to see which way the tracks run
but we can now combine this with light sheet uh
just some more uh just another one but here's
uh we can combine it with um
with functional mri so this is
a black six male uh mice over here and the
and the d2 the two parents just looking at
resting state fmi from marcelo fibo's group at the
the gainesville magnetic residence national center
and catherine kozrowski at jackson laboratory
so they've been doing mri of not only the
parents but they have been bold enough to do
start doing the the resting state connectome
uh the fmri connectome for the for the bxd
uh progeny children and so there's amazing
stuff that can be done and i uh just this morning
whoops coined this ridiculous word polyphenol so
a phenome should in principle be everything but
i just want to emphasize that this is really
everything everything including the environmental
perturbations uh the genetic perturbations so
we can do mri we can do light sheet we
can do proteomics of brain or any other
chunk we can do developmental studies epigenomics
behavioral studies obviously and you end up with
something like this a polytope or a matrix or a
tensor showing everything related to everything
else so in this case it's just a looking at the
variability of brain regions such as cortex with
other regions so you can see that the neocortex
doesn't really care much about the hindbrain
but it does care quite a bit about the striatum
which makes a good good deal of sense and call it
cares about so you can look at these correlation
structures again in a genetic context so imagine
the third dimension of this being the mapping data
for every one of those those cells in that matrix
and i think i wanted to show you okay so this is
a slide i wanted to show you now adding so we take
the brain in situ and we do the mri at about
45 micron resolution then the brain is removed
from the skull uh it of course gets distorted
when we do that we ding the cortex and we you
know an olfactory bulb or parafocus falls off
whatever it then goes to boston in life canvas uh
one of carl dies ross ace postdoc chung set up a
company called life canvas technology to basically
spread the word and spread the practice of shield
and clarity so the the these whole brains are then
clarified and you can then antibody you can
you know use as many as three four channels
to studies any cells you want so in this case
it's tyrosinase i'm sorry tyrosine hydroxylase
in dopaminergic neurons in the ventral midbrain
and then just a stain for gfp you can see the
resolution is in two orders of magnitude better on
a linear scale than what we achieve with the mri
so now you get the cytology but you've got it
in beautifully segmented regions of interest
from the mri which is unrivaled in terms of
distortion free analysis and i just want to
escape here for a second and show you
what some of these brains look like so
this is an egfp a brain that was imaged by mri
then sent to boston for imaging and you can count
every cell here that's expressing the enhanced
green fluorescent protein that's the trigeminal
motor nucleus you see over there you can see the
spinach corticospinal tracts looping down you can
see the projections from the subiculum looping
forward and every cell is countable here and so
you're doing whole brain potentially a whole
brain stereology now this is a pretty picture
pretty movie i'll tell you it's very much state of
the art to convert something like that to numbers
and that's where we're going now
with a lot of help from a lot of
a lot of folks let's see i want to get back
here to hang on a second while i clutz around
okay so that just if you want to go to
life canvas tech that that's their hero
screen though the one i just showed you they have
several hero screens but that's the first one um
so i've i'm up i'm at 11 37 now um so kind of
a new topic here and this has to do with why
animal models are coming in with the tremendous
for tremendous amount of intellectual flack
so you may not know it but nimh essentially won't
fund certain types of animal model work because
the the current director of nih happens to think
that mice don't mouse data doesn't translate well
and i hate to say it but he's absolutely correct
but he's absolutely correct for the wrong reasons
and that's because he and other leaders at
nih have allowed a sociology of n equals 1
to proliferate for the last 30 years so in the
interest of standardization we've been left with
one mouse so i would say that 90 95 of all
studies you read that use a mouse model
use one genome of mouse it's either c57
black 6j or c57 black 6 nj or it's bound cj
or it's fvb or it's btbr if you're interested in
autism this is completely ridiculous because it's
an n of one study i don't care if you studied
50 knockouts 50 heterozygous in 50 wild types
it is an n of one genome that you're studying and
you may consider the results to be necessary and
sufficient you may get your high profile paper in
neuron or cell or science but it is still an end
of one study and as a matter of fact it's less
than an n of one study because every mouse that
is studied is essentially a single genome it's
not even got the decency to have um two genomes
within its single body it's a fully inbred
strain of mouse so it's really an n of 0.5
in the same way that finally after about 40 years
nih decided to mandate that we shall study males
and females they're still letting us slide by
studying one genome type of mouse it's inexcusable
and it's doubly inexcusable because it
accounts almost perfectly for the failure
of transportability of data from mouse to human
and translations to fail because we don't even
have robust results for our mouse results
you get in c57 black six do not translate
to bound cj they do not translate to dba 2j they
certainly don't translate to rat why should they
it's like saying that this in this figure from
all of us that the old white guy in this figure
he's going to represent all of us so forget about
all that genetic diversity that all of us put in
their figure there no we're only going to study
uh 70 kilogram white guys that's what biomedical
research did for about 50 years as everybody
painfully knows finally we've gotten beyond that
we've gotten beyond that for uh human clinical
research but not for the billions of dollars we
spend every year on mouse and rat research so you
can you can kind of get a feel for the aggravation
that i have i just i just um i'm horrified by this
and i'm i'm glad to at least have a bully pulpit
here for for you know a few minutes to point out
this inexcusable stupidity of of what we're doing
so we cannot generalize so and all that genetic
variation has to go into our models so how do
we add variation to improve the transport and
translation to humans well my simple step has been
take two inbred strains at least mix them up
and now you've got a family a mixed up family
and here's the simple pedigree you know this goes
back to genetics not even 101 genetics one basic
basically mendel uh could have understood this
we've got two inbred strains black 6 and dba2j
we make the f1 inner cross which is shown
there f1 then we make an f2 intercross meiotic
randomization exactly what mendel did in 1864. and
the only trick is that we now once we get our f2
progeny we put them in a cage and inbreed them
for 20 generations and we end up with another
inbred strain actually we've got 152 of these
in strains that we've made and it costs about
25 to 30 000 to make each one of these strains
and so i'm thankful for funders for letting me
go off on this deep deep dive into making
resources um and i mentioned all of them have
been sequenced so that's what it looks like and
you can see we have this meiotic randomization
this is what fisher did starting in the 20s
so the randomization here comes from meiosis
which is more or less random that's very
close to being a randomizing process that
allows us to extract causality so what about
these bxds they're obviously adorable um
each strain here is immortal so that's why i said
you can come back to these strains in a hundred
years they're all cryopreserved yes mutations
will happen but you can roll it back in time by
getting your preserved stock each strain comes
in a male female version so this is incredibly
powerful in terms of looking at sex differences
if you do a paired t-test with an n of 150
with 10 males and 10 females per strain you've
got a pretty firm answer and it's not just for
one genotype of mouse it's for 150 genotypes that
are segregating for 6 million sequence variants
which is more than many human populations
including almost all of west eurasia
so actually almost everything other than african
populations so we've got this sequence we're
building pan genome assemblies for these uh
critters um they're extremely powerful for
mapping because a minor allele frequency is quite
high just like you'd expect for a linkage study
the precision with which you can map a causal
locus is on the order of uh half a megabase
to four megabases if you're willing to do 100
strains and there's a kicker here you can expand
this panel from 120 50 strains to essentially an
unlimited number of f1s effectively more f1s than
you can deal with and i'll show you that they can
i said nasty things i'm sorry for those of you who
study knockouts and knock-ins but the the nice
my my my mia culpa is you can take your knockout
and you can cross it into the to the bxd family
so we're doing this with the 5x fad alzheimer's
disease model you never have to genotype
these animals because we've done it for you
and you shouldn't study more than six cases per
strain for reasons that are shown right here
if you have a trait that has a heritability of
0.2 which is pretty low something like longevity
if you study 10 each your effective heritability
is now 0.7 simply because you've gotten rid of
the environmental noise or various noise sources
by averaging across genome types these mice are
also you can see ideal for gxe studies because i
can take each pair here and throw one of the mice
in one limb of the study and another in the other
limb so let's run a randomized controlled trial or
genome by environmental studies in the bxds here's
a study we did we're just finishing this with
76 bxd strains all females because we didn't
want them to fight and we wanted to do a
longevity study and males unfortunately beat
each other up in the cage we put half of them on
it on the normal chow diet and half of them on a
ridiculously high fat diet the blue diet for those
of you who know these things 60 calories from
fat it's basically like eating butter all day uh
longitudinal weighings and then we looked at life
span and you can see the high fat diet animals do
have on average a shorter life span it's about 85
days we've got two levels of causality going here
it's it's just a good randomized clinical
control where we basically randomize these
animals across the two treatment groups find
wonderful that's how you do it in humans
but we have another level which is the genetics
we have the central dogma we can map every
one of the traits we can go from dna to rna to
protein to trait and i should say variability of
here's what the these data look like where the
red are the ciao diet and the blue i'm sorry the
yeah and the blue are the high fat diet and you
can see oddly enough even though again i i could
give you a general recommendation hey you know
it's going to be good if you exercise every day
go out and walk or run five miles every day eat
right you're gonna live longer on average but you
are an individual not a population so here on
the super high fat diet there are some strains
that actually live longer on the high fat diet not
many but that one is significant even with all the
fdr correction and then we as you expect
most strains live longer on the channel
diet but this is one of the parents so that's
the father this is the mother this is the f1
so you can see the f1s don't care really whether
they're on a high fat or low fat it's pretty much
as a matter of fact they live a little bit longer
on the high fat so the one size fits all we've all
been taught that that that's not true anymore
that's what we call precision medicine but how
do you actually estimate who which which
human is going to profit from a high fat
diet which human is going to profit from
smoking cigarettes they're individuals with
parkinson's susceptibility loci who should smoke
cigarettes because it'll extend their lifespan
here's just a little surprise weight and weight
gains are not good predictors of longevity
and in the interest of time i won't go
through this but you can see these these
fits are pretty flat or parallel so they show
that the high fat diet's not really doing much
or i'm sorry the high fat diet is doing
something the weight gain is not doing much
and then uh the bayesian network analysis so uh
meiotic recombine uh there's something called
bayesian i'm sorry mendelian randomization that's
been introduced to epidemiology over the last
i guess it's about 25 years old but i think
it's really taken off in the last eight years
so you can get causality even out of
epidemiological studies now if you do it
in the right way the more standard way is just
to use kind of the judeo-pearl approach to do
structural bayesian network analysis this is a
bayesian network analysis run by jan sui using
the bayesian network web server companion
of gene network and here we're looking at
the effects of diet on total cholesterol
hdl free fatty acids triglyceride glucose
and trying to predict waited 500 days using all
the data i just showed you and you can see you
will you will see that there is no comparable
graph for longevity and that's because none of
these measures of ldl hdl glucose total caress
none of them were predictors of longevity which
was sort of a heartbreak on on one but but i am
perversely a guy who likes strong negatives and
it's a reasonably strong negative
with the way we designed the study
okay so we have we are now at ten minutes i
was going to say a hands-on interlude with gene
network i'm instead just going to conclude but go
to gene network and play with it it's a data loom
i'm going to skip this i did mention this you
can expand so everything i showed you was the
inbred strains i mentioned we have about 150
of these but there's no reason you can't make
any f1 off the diagonal they're all isogenic
they all have entirely predictable genomes
and they're 22 000 of those to get beyond mere
mechanism so i find mechanism a it's the wrong
word humans and mice are not clockworks we are
extremely messy and we're not machines we are
extremely messy i don't know whatever you
want to call it processes dynamic processes
this mecha word mechanism just i use it in
grant applications i even use it in papers
but every time i read it i cringe it's the wrong
metaphor is completely the wrong metaphor for
biological systems which do not have a necessary
and sufficient usually exceptions we really want
to get to robust causal models with defined
predictive accuracy and error and we're so
here's the kind of rhetorical question i answered
myself how long will it take us to reach a goal
of precision healthcare without experimental
platforms with the complexity of human cohorts
it's gonna it would take forever basically we
would never get there we need to have cohorts
for experimental precision medicine and right
now the bxds the collaborative cross and a few
other replicable populations are it that's it
there's equivalent for drosophila called the
drosophila diversity panel but there's not much
not nearly enough um and what you're looking at
there that matrix of everybody crossed to
everybody is called the dialel cross and i
that's where i'm going to be going in the
next 10 years i'm going off the diagonal
into the land of prediction i'm going to skip
this but it's kind of a fun slide for those of
you who are data scientists some cautions about
becoming a data scientist don't let the biologists
tread on you you guys are in charge the biologists
will always think they're in charge because they
know the problem may be better than you do but the
data generation process is critical and you should
you should take charge okay you know this is a
common lament of statisticians and data scientists
they get treated as super techs you do not want
to be a super tech you want to take charge of the
problem and take charge of the biology which is
easier than learning uh what you guys know so i
wish i knew matrix algebra i'll tell you that um
just want to come back to this lovely um 1939 um
piece of poetry by edna saint vincent
malay it's it's just it's an amazing uh
stanza of poetry i can't read it because it
makes me cry every time i read it it's just
i don't know how she dreamed this up
in 1939 but it should be everybody's uh
should be everybody's goal and prospects
so um we we want to align humans and mouse
uh we can't do it with just mike snyder and c57
black six we need a whole lot more than that
and i think i'll just open it to questions after
saying thanks to the people who and funding that
made this possible lots and lots of people helped
over the last 30 years this isn't even complete
but i want to just flank my collaborator
lulu who's been critical in generating
the animal resources and peter prince who
is the lead architect of gene network now
it's really um a lovely stack of code i couldn't
say this three years ago i couldn't even say it
three months ago we just finally lifted
it over to python three-point whatever
and just a call out for those of you who in
data science this this book by judea pearl
should be absolutely required reading the book of
why all 14 it is simple uh some of you might find
it insulting he's he's kind of got an assertive
dogmatic personality like somebody else i know
i really really recommend it though
because it'll allow you to see how ignorant
an entire field can be for 40 years so before
causal modeling came in uh the frequentest
approach completely [ __ ] for what we're doing
in my opinion and then thanks to a lot of funding
agencies in particular the governor's chair
and our center for integrative translational
genomics which has made it possible for me to do
crazy crazy stuff that i wouldn't have been able
to do had i stayed at yale okay thanks i'm
gonna stop share and i guess i'll start my
start the video that's great thank you so much
rob for that uh fantastic fantastic and visionary
like set of thoughts about uh how we deal with
data how we organize it and how it can actually
live beyond its years and almost be like you said
immortal and i think that's a very important point
is that data that we collect today if we organize
it properly and we can figure out ways to make it
available it can actually have a life well beyond
uh the time we collected it and by the people who
collected it into many other domains so your talk
is exactly spot on with some of the uh ideas that
i hoping our um our biomedical data science lab
participants will be able to share with each other
i i we have a couple of questions from um some of
our audience members here yep um and uh yeah uh
mentioning uh that you know you had discussed the
difficulty of managing data and databases for just
the average laboratory and what advice do you have
for people who are at the early stages of their
careers that may not yet have an r1 funding about
how they can plan make plans for managing their
data yeah uh i like so having lived through it my
advice would be don't don't don't shy away from
excel or access or filemaker or the equivalent
easy database systems um if you've got a large
flow of data in your lab let's say you're doing
behavioral studies and you expect to run through
you know 100 plus animals per year i would
recommend setting up a simple relational database
system um i'd suggest doing it in your own lab
jack and i were talking about cloud services i
personally don't recommend them i think they're
i think it's as i shouldn't say this probably
but you know you can buy a 20 terabyte hard drive
for 500 bucks and you can buy three of them for
1500 bucks and yeah it might be just a bunch of
disk drives but you you'll be able to manage it so
i would keep local control unless
there's a good reason not to
the the hardest thing about databasing is
getting making sure you're really good about
metadata and the header files for your data so i
i cannot tell you it takes it takes me probably
10 tries to get a new postdoc to realize that
i don't want to see their excel file without an
index on the far left going from one
to whatever and an index along the top
showing me how many columns of data they have
and there have to be at least 10 blank rows
above that above the data where they put all
their metadata who when where what why and
if you do that with excel you you add all those
who what where when why's at the header file
your that data file may be interpretable in 10
years if you stumble across it and can open it
but if it's just if it's just an anonymous
it's got some cryptic header data and no
index you have no idea the provenance you're
doomed so so the i guess the short answer to
tanya is metadata so if you whatever
if i don't care if you you do it in
hieroglyphics if the hieroglyphics
have metadata it's going to be fine
but but if it becomes a matter of throughput
then go to an easy to use relational database
don't let somebody convince you you have to do an
open source um code like mariadb or or postgres
because there you do need a lot of expertise
it's it's free and open but you need
command line competence so i would suggest if you
don't have that competence spend a weekend working
through filemaker pro or the equivalent uh get
competence filemaker pro now is a very competent
system so it use people used to you know they
put their their nose up and say oh it's just
it's not a relational database um it may not
be fully acid compliant like the big boys like
oracle but it's definitely good enough and you
can integrate it with all kinds of other services
so yeah well with that thank you so
much uh dr williams for that really
fantastic talk talking about data structures risk
for disease uh the environmental effects and and
uh how we can uh better organize our data and how
it can actually have usefulness well beyond its
original collection and uh be useful for folks
like the group we're talking to today is the
data scientists and how they could uh go to gene
network and start playing around i think that's
wonderful and exactly the type of thing i'd
love to see some of our participants uh doing
as soon as possible be awesome so uh with that
thank you so much robert i really appreciate it
everyone have a good weekend and uh we won't
see you next week because of thanksgiving but uh
enjoy your holiday thanks much and look
any any comments welcome follow up with
the email it's at the very beginning of the
presentation thanks again robert all right adios